[Musique]
le centre val de loire possède près d'un
millier de galeries souterraines pour
parler des troglos j'ai rendez vous avec
state et julie hommes et femmes des
cavernes ici à bourg et je vous promets
une visite chaleureuse mais un peu au
froid parce qu'il fait 12 degrés qui
était comme hiver alors bienvenue à
troglos b gusto la paix est une danse
danse de l'été troglos les ghosts autre
angle au dégoût store troglos des ghosts
en trois blocs et
[Musique]
ambiance
alors ça
salut l'ami
et ben si on m'avait dit qu'un jour je
ferai la fête dans une grotte
pour faire la fête donnée droite il faut
rencontrer steak l'homme des cavernes
bien volé ya combien de kilomètres de
gala digne et on descend de sa tombe et
en profondeur on a 35 km de galeries sur
trois petits niveaux c'est un véritable
dédale qui a été entièrement causés par
l'homme à la main pour et seulement pour
l'extraction de la pierre de tuffeau
lance-pierre des châteaux la pierre des
rois ce moteur de construction qui a
fait la richesse de notre centre val de
loire l'endroit était abandonné bien
malgré lui pendant une vingtaine
d'années et nous l'avons réhabilité en
lieu de vie un lieu de culture en lieux
d'art en lieu d'histoire de patrimoine
de terroir voilà pour permettre aux
visiteurs de découvrir notre territoire
notre destination par le prisme de ses
mondes souterrains mais avant d'y aller
d'abord
musique
dans ces deux mois
ait idir dispose c'est bon ça
or des mois un petit peu de là découlera
des bouts de bois qu'on voit sur le mur
c'est magnifique ça là ce sont des pieds
de vie qu'ils ont eue quarantaine
d'années de vie de bons et loyaux
services alors autre chose qui
m'interpelle joint ses marques et
clément tous les jours ou propose à des
enfants et aux plus aux plus jeunes avec
des petits outils de tailleur de pierre
devenir graver leur nom directement sur
la roche et ce pour toujours écoutez
c'est reparti on y retourne
[Musique]
alors là c'est le coin ne jubilent ici
effectivement on est sur un domaine
viticole dans les entrailles de la roche
et du terroir donc on élève nos vins
pétillants ici
ouais vous êtes vous également d'aider
des logements quoi oui il ya des apparts
bienvenue chez toi tu m'écoutes merci à
bourg manque usi cuisine équipée je rêve
j'ai des potes ils sont étudiants à
paris n'ont pas un logement comme ça
là l'eau puis on avance plus le plafond
est bas j'ai moi j'ai droit à la méthode
michael jackson de thriller pour avancer
et ça que je peux faire d'ici là
voilà kabylie je te présente top notre
artiste plasticien saluant chanter
bonjour tom alors qu'est ce qui vous a
amené ici à réaliser une oeuvre fait
tomber amoureux de la carrière j'ai
vraiment adoré avec toute toute cette
histoire gravé dans la roche et je me
suis dit mais j'ai fait un truc qui est
vraiment gravés dans la pierre à
l'ancienne pour pour que ça reste dans
le temps et pour montrer un peu ce
travail travailler des personnes en fait
qui sont venus ce crime est ici toute
leur vie par contre visiblement vous
n'êtes pas à baisser suffisamment quand
vous marchez dans la grotte départ du
tout vos cheveux et je me ferai pas moi
ça a frotté il a tout perdu je me ferais
pas voir les galants lot sûrement limbo
et tout est faux parce que je me dire
que apprend en raquettes et l art ou
incrusté dans le mur comme ça on vous la
bo aussi du coup ouais ça c'est un signe
et je vais vous dire pourquoi c'est
aussi parce que le team de l'émission
c'est 15 min en roue libre au centre val
de loire alors voilà j'intègre l'oeuvre
du true blood et gusteau c'est pas beau
ça franchement sauf que non elle croit
ces photos lui donnerait ce qu'il faut
pour ça ah ouais d'accord avec
[Musique]